uh last one for me
um so wait so do you get mine
uh you want four picks uh what are you
doing oh okay all right good just wanted
to make sure
wait didn't brady teach you it's one two
three
four i knew it was third down all along
oh fourth down i mean
that's good
well done that helmet looks a little
snug a little snuggly
i looked i looked a little green do you
notice that yeah you notice that i
looked green you're just confused and
you just threw an interception on fourth
down you thought it was third what are
you doing
um
now now look i
i don't want to belabor the point
because i have a feeling he's going to
be one of the goats in a bad way in the
draft coming up but but
uh here's tom brady's congratulatory
tweet to lebron james after
james won his fourth title congrats to
my brother king james on winning his
fourth championship not bad for a washed
up old guy he uses the photo of brady's
body and arm with the four from thursday
night with lebron james uh taking the
place of brady's head
uh
it's it's tom you're not allowed to make
light of your mistake from the other
night until you own it yeah right i
think that's you can't that i think
that's just a rule of self-deprecation i
agree you can't you can't refuse to own
the mistake and then get in on the act
of everyone who is punking you
for your mistake right i think that's
just that's just basic etiquette
of making fun of yourself you have to
admit the mistake before you can join in
the fun that everyone is making of you
yeah that's right i mean you can't
capitalize on the like the the fruits of
the labor here when you didn't want to
like yeah admit wrong
when it the game was over you know that
that i can't lie that rubbed me the
wrong way it did it really did like
i don't know
if you're a superstar you're not allowed
to make a mistake ever anymore and admit
that is that the world we're in just
deny deny deny deny i mean to me it made
me mad because it's like stop playing me
like an idiot stop playing me like an
idiot okay you can't yell at rookie
receivers last year in new england and
then yell at the offensive lineman
during the game the other night put them
on blast on national tv on everybody and
then when it comes to your mistake the
whole organization has to find some way
to finagle it so you don't feel so bad
come on that's bullcrap yeah that is
lack of etiquette i don't even know what
that is that's bad and let me let me
tell you when bruce arians
covers for you twice
that tells me
that tommy was not happy
with what aryans did after week one even
though
nobody's ever gonna say any of it
publicly
but
aryans in my estimation got the message
that his usual habit
of publicly trashing anyone who deserves
it
stops
when it comes to the goat the goat in a
good way yeah but i have a feeling he's
gonna be one of the goats in a bad way
and i'm gonna give you the first pick no
trivia question today even if you do
take tom brady although that'll be my
first pick if you don't okay well then
i'll take it then okay i'll take it yeah
i'm of course i'm gonna take that i mean
come on this is the goat right i mean he
is one of the greatest of all time
there's no doubt about that everything
he did
all of that but yeah that was a big that
was a big moment i mean that really was
so uh to lose track of the downs hey
should somebody have probably reminded
them on tampa yes no there's no doubt
i'm not trying to give them you know
an escape hatch here but brady's played
enough football 20 years in the game
awesome everything like that it's just
rare that he messes up a mistake like
that and doesn't realize the down and
the situation of the football game so
because of that and the game was still
on the table there and there was
somebody open on that play underneath
and all of that uh yes he will be my
first pick of the goat draft
and you compound the mistake by refusing
to own up to it it's an opportunity for
him to have a human moment we all make
mistakes yep we all screw up at times
it's okay right they're not going to cut
him if he admits that he made the
mistake they're not going to stop the
production of his eventual bust that's
going to go into canton and i've said
before he could have two bus in canton
one for his career pre-2008 one for his
career post 2008. none of that changes
it just makes him look small it really
does admit your mistakes
you know life goes on and when everyone
knows you made the mistake you refuse to
admit it just makes you look
not good yeah speaking of guys who
looked not good this week phillip rivers
the two interceptions the ugly one we
talked about earlier that ronnie
harrison was just like hey look at this
there's a football i'll grab it and oh i
run that way okay touchdown for me
um the the safety
that that uh that he took um yeah that
was his fault and
like there was a guy bearing down on him
but but still
it it just was it was an ugly moment and
uh it was an ugly game for philip rivers
and and i don't i'm not saying this to
be proven right because i had ver i had
very real doubts about him after last
season and he defied those doubts for
three weeks but now it's back to kind of
what it was week one and last year where
you know hey they asked the question of
frank reich for a reason as to whether
or not jacoby bersette may replace
philip rivers the people who cover the
team are seeing it the fans are seeing
it we're seeing it and he deserves that
designation after how he played against
the browns yeah that that's right well
we've seen two games where like they
kind of put it in like okay you're gonna
put it in your hands we're gonna throw
the ball a little bit more and those are
the games they've lost jacksonville and
and last week to where i was a little
surprised like we talked about they
didn't play through the run but you're
right mike i mean the safety was his
fault there's no there's no denying that
if he just steps up in the pocket
there's nobody there he literally
floated back to where miles garrett
never had to turn the corner he just ran
a straight diagonal line and that's
where philip rivers was so his pockets
awareness and then the pick six that
cost him nine points in the second half
and of course that was a difference in
the game all right so
i'm gonna go to
your minnesota vikings you're i'm bingo
yeah yeah i gotta do it i mean i gotta
go with alexander madison of course just
because of the hole that was there on
fourth and half a foot
what hole that hole with the big yellow
that we saw there
go that way right i mean i i don't want
to put i want to put it on him the you
know everybody on the vikings offense or
just not putting that game away but
obviously um he put his head low and
tried to just dig into a little you know
daylight or crack of light there and he
missed a huge hole there that would have
been an easy first down all the way so
i'll make him uh one of my goats of the
week
yeah the gail sayers saying is 18 inches
of daylight not 18 feet of daylight
which is what alexander madison had mike
zimmer by the way the coach of the
vikings who made the decision to go for
it in that spot said monday he would do
it again and
that's what you expect you can't show
any lack of resolve right you still have
to be the guy who runs your team you
have to show faith in your god i'm
showing faith in my guys and i'll show
faith in my guys again even though
they're giving me reason not to show
faith in them all right next one for me
uh let's go to last night michael
badgley
mike williams makes one of the great
catches of the season
has his helmet ripped off you know comes
down lands hard on his back with two
guys on top of him that's the moment
where we all say man the chargers are
going to beat the saints the saints are
going to be two and three holy crap out
comes michael badgley for a 50-yarder
which once upon a time was a big deal
but now 50 yards like a 37-yarder was
back in the 70s
and he stunks it off the upright and it
was weird because it kind of it looked
like it was going to go through yeah it
did because it hit the inside of the of
the pipe and i thought at first it was
going to carry him in and it falls
straight down and then the chargers
losing over time so sorry money badger
if you're gonna try to be called
money badger
you got to be money money
and you weren't
no you're you're right uh it is it's
funny how you for whatever reason right
now with kickers too i feel more
confident when they're gonna kick a
50-yard field goal than i do when
they're gonna kick the extra point for
whatever reason too i don't know what
that is right now and their psyche or my
psyche uh but
yeah that was rough typical chargers
lost all right i'm gonna go to one here
that really got
not enough attention last week and the
team won so he got bailed out here the
head coach all right but i'm going back
to that bucks bears game i'm going back
to that matt nagy okay
second and nine pass play
on when the game is they're running out
the clock
and you leave tom brady
a minute and 13 seconds left to all he
has to do is go down and kick a field
goal
that to me was one of the dumber moves
of the weekend they missed an
opportunity where there should have been
40 seconds left more more off the clock
i mean really
they should have got the ball there and
brady should have snapped the first play
probably with 30 something seconds left
in the game if matt nagy runs uh runs
the ball
on second and third down you know he ran
it on third but on second of course he
threw it incomplete stopped the pass so
that to me was such horrible game
management and they were so fortunate to
win the game
with brady messing up and all of that
because if they didn't i think everybody
would still be talking about how matt
nagy blew it in in an easy run the clock
out situation
i'm torn for my last when i was thinking
about aj green there's that clip of the
interception and him making multiple
business decisions to the point where he
ultimately sprinted away from the area
of the contact to avoid uh
impinging upon his future earning
ability but you know what look it's done
for him in cincinnati i can't fault him
for that and they they didn't lose that
game because of him you can make the
argument the eagles lost the game
because of doug peterson's decision
to trot out jake elliott for a 57-yard
field goal in a stadium where no 57-yard
field goal had ever been made yeah right
and you you it's one thing to say hey my
guy's got the leg he may have the leg in
any other stadium and he did have the
distance but it's got to be the distance
and the accuracy sometimes when you put
that extra on it because you know you
have to put the extra on it because of
the the winds and just the way it is at
heinz field that's what causes it to go
askew
so it's fourth and five fourth and five
um and again it's easy with hindsight
but i 57 yards at heinz field not the
thing to do not the spot for that
especially when you have other options
uh so i agree with you doug peterson is
my last person or a punk ball i mean
what was wrong with that i mean they're
the pittsburgh defense wasn't doing i
mean offense wasn't doing anything
special so i i don't get that one either
you're right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports